Prince Harry and his American fiance
Megan Marco will make their first
official appearance together tomorrow
one big question about this courtship is
unanswered this morning the name of
their mutual friend who brought them
together Charlie d'Agata is outside
London's Kensington Palace with what we
know about this unnamed person Charlie
good morning good morning from outside
what will be one of the marital homes of
Prince Harry and Megan Markel has all
kinds of curiosity about the details of
the wedding but what people want to know
first is who played Cupid we were
essentially by a mutual friend we should
protect her privacy well too much of
that and but it was it was it was so who
was that mystery matchmaker britain's
media's certainly scrambling to find out
the frontrunner violet von Weston Holtz
a member of the British aristocracy who
used to work for Ralph Lauren where she
reportedly met Marco Marco posted
pictures of her and Von Weston Holtz at
Wimbledon in June last year around the
time she met her dashing Prince von
Weston Holtz wouldn't confirm her role
but told Britain's Daily Telegraph it's
a great story and I'm sure they're going
to be very happy together
also in contention mutual friend fashion
designer Mischa nunu seen here with
Marco her ex-husband apparently went to
the same school as Harry and even in the
gilded world of Hollywood royalty meets
actual royalty there was a surprising
innocence surrounding that first date
yes it was definitely a setup I didn't
know much about him and so the only
thing that I had asked her when she said
she wanted to set us up was having one
question I said was he nice nice is one
word to describe Prince Harry who
seemingly doesn't own a television
that's because because you were too busy
ogling me to listen to a word I've said
I've never never even heard about it
until this friend said make a mock cause
like right a cake give me give me
groan it's like what's going on here
when I walked into that room and saw her
and that she was sitting there I was
like okay why hurry I don't love my
daddy
well he certainly upped his game within
a few weeks he had wished Megan off to
Africa they camped under the stars in
Botswana now we're about to hear wedding
bells all thanks to the friend who set
them up Nora yeah a very good friend
yeah Mia Prince but I think it's great
when people say to Megan look what
you're giving up and she said I don't
think I'm giving up anything I think I'm
gaining a new chapter in my life
yeah and I'm looking very forward to
that and the fact that she wanted to
know is he nice and the heath said I
have to up my game there Prince Harry
was a little we are talking about like
Edward the eighth in the abdication but
there's a much similar thing with
Princess Margaret and Group Captain
Peter Townsend yeah the Queen refused to
allow them to get married yes they look
good together
thank you again Charlie d'Agata he was
outside Kensington Palace